you're ready to history ready you ready
okay all right I'm Holman loans to live
words and this is history club where
Phil and I tell each other a story from
history that ideally the other one
doesn't know anything about so today is
my turn and it's a story of sabotage
deception and spies culminating in a
major attack on US soil in 1916 all
right right here on black Tom Island so
black Tom was a munitions depot during
World War one and one summer night in
1916 German spies blew it to pieces and
they almost got away with it okay so a
really important thing to know about
this whole story
is that the US government badly wanted
to remain neutral when World War one
broke out in Europe and for the first
few years of the war they were they saw
the war as a sort of old world problem
thousands of miles away and US President
Woodrow Wilson promised to keep the
people out of it yeah staying out of
World War one was kind of one of the
cornerstones of his re-election campaign
yes but that didn't mean they couldn't
profit from it the salient shipment of
munitions to Europe became a major
industry in the United States and
brought the country out of an economic
downturn and they were pumping this bit
out so I'm I couldn't your map and you
know Europe you know Europe looks like
so yes now I meant now imagine Europe so
it's a lines shapes this industry mainly
benefited the antón allies led by Great
Britain France and Russia and the
Central Powers led by Germany and
austria-hungary could technically also
buy American bombs but they were
excluded because of a really effective
blockade the British Navy had imposed at
the beginning of the war getting
munitions into Germany was basically
impossible so Germans turned to the next
best thing
sabotage I'm gonna do the short version
of this but the go-to source for the
bigger story is this book starting in
1914 and up until the u.s. entered the
war in 1917 Imperial Germany operated a
sophisticated network of spies and
saboteurs inside the US secretly
wreaking havoc on the munitions industry
ships and factories were catching fire
and suspicions landed on Germans and
German Americans
and there were a lot of Germans here
including sailors who because of the
British blockade were sort of stranded
in neutral US ports and that is where
they were being recruited to blow up
factories and was the appeal just one of
nationalism these people were from
Germany and so they should help the
German effort yeah they saw it as like
as attacks on the English because that
the English and the Russians were buying
these bombs so it's like these are being
sent straight to people who are gonna
use these on Germans you can't fight the
war because you're stuck here do you
want to do this instead one of my
favorite parts of this whole thing is
this guy von Bernstorff I'm send you a
picture of him Germany's ambassador to
Washington was secretly overseeing this
entire spy network while trying to
maintain good relations with the US at
first the plan was to buy up all the
munitions before the Allies could but
the sheer scope of US production was
overwhelming German agent Franz von
ritalin remarks that the daily
production was so great that if I bought
up the market on Tuesday it would still
have been an enormous fresh supply on
Wednesday so he started setting fire to
Europe bound ships loaded with weapons
using a very special device and I wanted
to go into how it works but it's too
long but basically it could be timed to
go off after several days so by the time
the ship is far out to sea a massive
flame will ignite in the hold and they
burned so hot that it would melt the
casing of the bomb so there was no trace
of it which is an ideal weapon if you
want the fire to look like an accident
so Americans were suspicious of German
sabotage but they couldn't prove it and
that's because at this time there was no
infrastructure of domestic intelligence
agencies in the US no department
homeland security no FBI no CIA pre-war
one America saw itself as isolated and
safe protected from foreign attacks by
thousands of miles of ocean which
explains why they left their biggest
prize virtually unguarded 75 percent of
the u.s. is booming munitions industry
centered around New York and New Jersey
and most of them were shipped from black
Tom the night of July 30th the
warehouses and train cars were packed to
the brim with over two million pounds of
munitions making it possibly the largest
Arsenal in the
world outside of the war zone and at
2:08 in the morning it blew up glass
windows shattered all across Jersey City
lower Manhattan and Brooklyn
the massive Brooklyn Bridge shuttered
and people as far away as Philadelphia
in Maryland felt the blast which would
have registered as a moderate earthquake
on the Richter scale Statue of Liberty
was struck too and it's damaged torch
has been closed to visitors ever since
the attack so you used to be able to
actually go to the very top of the torch
but it's been closed since 1916 Wow I
never knew that yeah so the torch was
damaged that way yeah it was damaged by
shrapnel bombs yeah all told there are
only five confirmed deaths and around 20
million dollars in property damage which
is about half a billion today Wow yeah
black Tom itself was obliterated and the
US had no idea how it happened and so
when did the United States recognize
that it was German spies who had been
responsible for blacktop it took years
at first there wasn't much suspicion of
sabotage at all black tom was seen as an
act of gross negligence and two guys
were initially arrested for manslaughter
the next prevailing theory was
mosquitoes for a long time the like
accepted sequence of events was that the
fire started after the handful of guards
working that night lit smudge pots which
are these things that you smoke - keep
away mosquitoes okay I was wondering I
was imagining mosquitoes wearing little
little robber masks sneaking in some
more Bavaria see the mosquitoes or it's
negligence and manslaughter but all the
investigating parties initially agreed
that it definitely wasn't sabotage
the year after black Tom the u.s. cut
diplomatic ties with Germany and entered
World War one
it wasn't until in 1939 that the US
declared Germany responsible for blowing
up black Tom along with other acts of
sabotage
they just weren't equipped to handle an
investigation like this nothing like it
had ever happened before
and I want to read one more quote from
the Washington evening star in 1919 the
whole sordid black Tom Kingsland episode
has served one good purpose however it
has shown the need in this country of an
efficient counter espionage system in
time of peace as well as war the German
sabotage campaign set the stage for the
passage of the Espionage Act in 1917 and
the eventual establishment of domestic
intelligence agencies so what is your
what attracted you to this story black
Tom is like the the signature attack of
this campaign but like the spy ring I
think is what gets me the most just this
amazing spy network that these German
diplomats set up and we're operating
four years inside the u.s. I just like
think about in America that isn't what
it is today where we record everything
and keep tabs on everyone you know it
was just like this could have only
happened free global America
[Music]